hey everybody let me tell you a story
[Music]
so I recently got back into minecraft
after a couple years away I've got a
little private friends and family server
set up I've built some nice things done
a lot of exploring having a lot of fun
and then one evening a friend says hey
let's go tame some cats now I'm of
course completely on board with this
plan pet cats sign me up
so in the current version of Minecraft
this entails finding a village because
the mechanical spawn trigger for feral
cats is related to the number of
villagers in an area so you find a
village and then hang out until you hear
a feral cat then you give the cat some
fish until it adopts you and now you've
got a pet cat the problem is that just
with how our world spawned and the way
we all chose to disperse around the area
before this point the closest villages
are kind of far away and aren't
connected to any of the rivers that
we're using as our main transport
corridor so we make this trip a few
times and it's always kind of a hassle
but hanging out around the village
exposes me to a bunch of the other
things you can do with villagers that
the game has added over the years see
the last time I played you could
basically only use extremely rare
emeralds to trade for random stuff in a
barter system with absolutely no concept
of value like you'd have to dig up these
emeralds that could only be found in one
specific type of place in the world the
large Hills biome and then some villager
would offer you like a pair of leather
pants for three emeralds and you're just
like hey thanks there's three cows full
of leather right over here but wow great
deal really it's not really a great deal
that's when we call sarcastic oh here
intend engaging like you go to one
villager and you can sell them a bunch
of wheat for emeralds then you can take
those emeralds to another villager and
buy a cursed book or something or just
hoard emeralds pack them into a block
and build a solid emerald bathtub I'm
not your dad anyway this seems like it
could be a lot of fun there's still just
that one
problem that the closest villages are
kind of far away and in the wrong
direction from everything else we're
building and wouldn't it be so much
easier for everyone to play with these
mechanics if we had a village like right
here in this giant empty field located
conveniently between a farm a dark
forest and a to-scale recreation of
Notre Dame carved out of a mountain yes
it absolutely would be so you know
what's set to work building a small
village with nice little houses using
the wood and materials that are nearby
build a fountain seed some farms get it
all decorated place a bunch of job sites
so the villagers have something to do
and now what the game designers have
their own vision of how this is supposed
to work they don't really want you to
just set up a village of your own
convenience so just building a village
isn't enough what they want is for the
player to find an existing village and
adopt and expand it to build up
something that's already there and
they've constructed mechanics in a way
to encourage this approach and
discourage anything else by making it
really inconvenient
you can't just lure villagers with food
or set up a village and expect them to
just pop into existence if you want to
create a new village without using
console commands to just create
villagers then you really only have two
options the first is to cut down trees
until you have an apple mine eight
blocks of gold smelt the gold into
ingots combine the ingots and apple into
a Golden Apple build a portal to Hell
using obsidian explore hell until you
find a nether fortress search the nether
fortress until you encounter several
flying enemies called blaze kill them
until you have at least two blaze rods
use one blaze rod to make a brewing
stand and the other to fuel the brewing
stand
use a bottle of water plus a fermented
spiders eye which is made using a
mushroom sugar and regular spiders eye
to create a potion of weakness then add
gunpowder to make a splash potion of
weakness hang around your new village
waiting for a rare zombie villager to
spawn in tomb them in blocks throw the
splash potion of weakness on them feed
them the Golden Apple and then leave
them entombed for another 5 minutes real
time
so they don't burn up in the sunlight at
dawn and then finally the villager will
be cured of undeath and you'll need to
do this twice because one villager does
not a village make alternately you're
going to need to acquire villagers from
existing villages and right here is
probably where you pause for a second
squint your eyes and go mm-hmm not so
sure about that phrasing they're not
hype on where this is going so at this
point I go through the time consuming
process of expanding an existing River
to make it ready for boat traffic
because you see villagers can't just be
lured away but if they get into a
vehicle like a boat or a minecart they
can't get out on their own it's just a
matter of getting a villager near enough
to the water that you can push them into
a boat or maybe you first need to set up
an elaborate trap with a minecart that
will first take them down to the river
so that you can then push them into a
boat sail that boat halfway around the
world and then push them out into their
new home and again of course you're
going to need to do this a few times
because a lone villager can't have kids
and it may take a village to raise a
child but it also takes a bunch of
children to make a village and so yes
the best most straightforward way to
create a new village in Minecraft is to
kidnap villagers from an existing
village now this is a good point to say
that I don't believe this is intentional
that this is more of a weird emergent
outcome of systems interacting I mean I
really hope that the people working on
Minecraft both on the Mojang and
Microsoft sides of things didn't look at
the game and go yeah human trafficking
pushing people into a boat in spirit way
I love it that would that would
definitely be a yikes
but it's a particularly interesting case
study in the way that game systems
create metaphor and that even if you
didn't intend for your mechanics to
incentivize kidnapping you still sort of
created a game where the player is kind
encouraged to do a kidnapping or two or
three and it should be
noted this interaction doesn't just
mimic kidnapping but more specifically
the brutal relocation policies of
colonialism shove some people in a boat
translocate them off somewhere else push
him out and say okay this is your home
now and the whole uncomfortable metaphor
is exacerbated by some of the smaller
details villagers all have a regional
look so even though they are
mechanically identical there's
definitely a sense of villagers taken
elsewhere being out of place villagers
in the player-character are both
humanoid but distinct from one another
they are different groups the villagers
have large noses and talk in a nonsense
Simlish across multiple vectors the
group with agency players are delineated
from the group without none of these
individual details are per se bad but
they do collectively build a scenario
where the player can easily otherwise
human NPCs this gets pretty dark when
players are indirectly incentivized to
abduct them or even industrialize them
like chattel such as this contraption
that exploits villagers summoning
Guardian iron golems as an infinite
automated source of iron for making
tools as much as I love building and
constructing games these kinds of issues
these metaphors hang over the head of
the genre whether they're created from
mechanics or from the intrinsic framing
of the games scenario in the 2019 essay
collection video games in the global
self
Jules cotton as Brown observes in an era
when physical space has been thoroughly
explored virtual spaces harken back to
the romance of the colonial frontier as
new regions to discover and conquer such
conquest is not just psycho symbolic but
also sensitive to the legacies of
colonialism and under development since
most mainstream video games are produced
and disseminated in the developed world
they are spaces in which primarily X
colonial nations can continue to conquer
the other even in post-colonial periods
in sandbox building games such as
minecraft the player arrives
Robinson Caruso into a terra nullius and
encourages him to improve this land by
clearing jungles draining marshes
building infrastructure and mining
minerals its inhabitants hostile
monsters or local villagers appear
simply as obstacles in the path of
development or as resources to exploit
and he's not wrong
I mean yeah a lot of those underlying
reasons are why I enjoy construction
games particularly minecraft I like
exploring I like building things I like
terraforming I enjoy bridges and towers
and villages and boats and trains and
that's not to say that those interests
are illegitimate but it does speak to
deeper cultural values that I have
inherited
I like terraforming and building big
things in part because I was raised in a
culture that values terraforming and
building big things a culture that looks
at the New York skyline the Hoover Dam
and the trans-canada highway and sees
first and foremost progress a culture
that sees these things as good my
interests and values are authentic but
they didn't form in a vacuum and this is
a value set that informs the entire
genre minecraft factorio satisfactory
stone hearth dwarf fortress towns timber
and stone no man's sky no Morea even the
relatively constrained stardew valley is
enamored with the romance of taming the
wilderness it is certainly interesting
that in a genre crowded with options
there are multiple games where the
player builds vast labyrinthian
factories to extract resources on an
alien planet and not one where the
player reclaims a planet from the
extractors carefully balancing wetlands
and ecosystems I mean is the food chain
of a marsh any less complex than
assembling red chips in factorio now
this is not me saying that all these
games form a deliberate block of Pro
colonial propaganda in fact all of them
to some degree or another are aware of
that legacy and try
to steer gently away from the issue by
fabricating scenarios where the behavior
is in some way or another justified or
permissible all of them have a reason
for doing what you're doing the
protagonist in factorio for example
isn't a colonist but is stranded on an
alien planet by accident and given the
implicit goal of leaving in no man's sky
the protagonist is adrift in a universe
where no one belongs a space too vast
for any one person to make a meaningful
impact a place devoid of villagers to
displace again they all have reasons for
doing what you're doing but these are
just explanations not excuses in many
ways these works of fiction are
indulging in a air-quote clean version
of history
what if America but no Native Americans
also dear factorio developers I love
your game but this wording here woof
this sense of insignificance is a
through-line we can see in a lot of
these even to a degree minecraft the
relative powerlessness of the individual
in the scope of the systems they are
interacting with as with no man's sky
Minecrafts world is unfathomably vast
about 900 million square kilometers it
is impossible for an individual to truly
alter the nature of the world but even
that narrative isn't new prairie fires
by Carolyn Fraser outlines how tales of
rugged individualism were used to
downplay excuse and dismiss the
institutionalized displacement and
massacre of indigenous Americans how in
books like Little House on the Prairie
authors like Laura Ingalls Wilder took
colonization and turned it into a
thousand tiny quaint stories not the
product of policy culture and values but
the lamentable byproduct of a thousand
individuals each too small to truly
alter the nature of the world so the
question then is how do we navigate this
it is perhaps tempting to fall into an
all-or-nothing proposition and just
throw the whole lot
but that is in my estimation at least
immature it is possible to interrogate
our collective past the world that we
have inherited and determined that
bridges and boats and trains are okay
and good that building things and even
altering the environment are things that
are or can be good that it is possible
to explore in a way that is better than
our own history that all these things
are themselves value-neutral and it is
up to us to engage them morally this is
also where there is a great value in
ensuring that voices from different
backgrounds different cultures are given
space to create to maybe argue against
permanence to argue the viewpoints of
the colonized is it possible to tell
these kinds of stories stories of
exploring the unknown without creating a
fantasized idealized version of our own
colonialist past I I don't know I don't
have an answer for that maybe and at the
very least maybe we won't end up with
games where you push villagers into
boats to haul them away